nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
i want to start today with something
i've mentioned before but i think
it's um really time to have a more
detailed
conversation about and this is what i'm
calling and some others are calling
coronavirus vaccine alarmism which
really has to stop now i want to be
really clear
coronavirus vaccine alarmism
i'm not talking about anti-vax people
here
i'm not talking about people who say the
vaccine is unsafe
or that it's microchipped or that bill
gates has some nefarious role to play or
that it's a population control device or
that
it modifies your dna that's anti-vaxx
what i'm talking about here is
what i guess makes sense to call vaccine
alarmism which is people who are
fine with vaccines as far as we know
but the sort of disproportionate focus
on the vaccines aren't 100 effective
um we don't know if anything can change
when you are vaccinated and other types
of talking points that are inadvertently
maybe
reducing interest in the vaccine and by
so doing
are actually going to have the effect of
extending the pandemic
the new york times had a great article
about this called
vaccine alarmism by david leonhardt
looking at the costs of vaccine alarmism
and in the article david points out that
there are hot takes and opinion pieces
being widely published right now that
start with something like
listen the coronavirus vaccine is not
100 effective
if you are vaccinated you might still be
able to transmit the disease to other
people
the variants might make the vaccines
irrelevant
and no one's behavior can change
even when vaccinated for a really long
time without making it clear what needs
to change for people's behavior to be
able to change
and when you kind of take it all
together it starts to sound like
well the pandemic will never end and the
vaccine change is nothing for me
so why even go through the hassle of
looking for an appointment and getting a
vaccine
especially if it's not 100 effective and
you can still
transmit the disease and you can't
change your behavior in any way
for the foreseeable future now if you
break down
it actually functions much like a
conspiracy theory you hear it all
together and it's like wow yeah that
that that's a lot
but if you break down each piece into
its
component parts you find that while
there is
some truth to each individual claim
there is so much missing context
and you end up with a completely
distorted view about vaccines let's
actually do it and break it down
for example the vaccine is not 100
effective
okay yeah that's true but with the
pfizer and moderna vaccines
at 92 to 95 effective these
are some of the most effective vaccines
in the history of vaccination and
importantly
not only are they 92 to 95 effective
they are almost 100 effective at
preventing
serious covet and so uh when you start
hearing well it's not a hundred percent
effective
i don't know that is extraordinarily
misleading
and it is a uh huge huge huge
additional amount of information you
need beyond they're not 100 effective
they're not 100 effective but they're
of the most effective vaccines we've
ever had and they are almost 100
effective at preventing severe covet
which is what's killing people
okay next it is true that vaccinated
people
may still be contagious what that means
is that the phase 3 trials on which the
vaccines were approved
didn't look at the effect of the
vaccines on transmissibility
however early data from israel suggests
that what was expected is
what is happening which is that these
vaccines pfizer and moderna
do reduce transmission again it's not
been studied and reported in a
peer-reviewed study and we want to be
careful
but the early information from israel
corroborates what was expected which is
that we expected the vaccines
would cut transmission hasn't been
studied
in the way that it needs to be studied
so uh then we get to
even if you get a vaccine you can't
change your behavior
for a really really long time okay let's
dig into that
in more detail it is true
that just getting a shot doesn't mean
that right away you should be doing
anything differently particularly if
nobody else in your circles is
vaccinated
but once you are fully vaccinated
meaning you're seven days past your
second dose
the risk from being with other fully
vaccinated people
especially if they work from home is
very
very low and again with everyone being
vaccinated
you are reducing the risk below that of
the flu
because the vaccines are so effective at
preventing severe covet so
does it make the risks zero no it
doesn't but nothing has zero risk
during flu season particularly with flu
vaccines only twenty to fifty percent
effective
uh we are accepting a certain level of
risk when we're around people during
that time
increasingly virologists and
immunologists and others are
understanding
that the vaccine is being undersold
dr muj zevic who's a virologist
said in the new york times piece our
discussion about vaccines has been poor
really poor as scientists we need to be
more careful
what we say and how it would be
understood by the public
and the focus has been uncertainty
possible bad news and it's making people
not want the vaccine
the vaccine isn't a catch-all do
whatever the hell you want
sort of get out of jail free card the
policies and grocery stores will be for
masks
for some time to come also at doctor's
offices and other lots of other places
no doubt
but let's be more realistic a small
group of fully vaccinated people who
work from home
can responsibly choose to accept
the small risk of being together
and part of the problem and part of the
reason why we need
all of the fear uncertainty and doubt to
be the top line
is that so many people either don't
understand a lot of this stuff or can't
use sound judgment so
everybody has to be extra careful but
the reality is
the more people that get the vaccine
more quickly
the sooner normality or something like
it can return
so we have to stop underselling the
vaccine
we have to make clear that a lot of
these catch-all umbrella statements
are uh making people disinterested in
the vaccine and that's only going to
prolong the pandemic no one is
advocating
irresponsible behavior some of these
headlines that are floating around
are a disaster and they are making it so
that
so many people don't want the vaccine
i'll have an example of this
later today for you in the voicemail
segment for the time being let's move on
to a few other things
the green new deal the green new deal is
not the law
the green new deal hasn't been passed uh
in the house and senate and signed by
the president the green new deal
isn't policy anywhere and yet
republicans more and more
are blaming the green new deal for the
power failure in texas
that we saw over the last week to 10
days how is this possible
this would be like blaming medicare for
all for a problem
when medicare for all isn't the law in
the united states
here is an example cancun cruz a
republican texas senator ted cruz who
recently
fled over the u.s mexico border with his
family to mexico when the power went out
at his house in texas
only to come back 20 hours later after
his escape attempt blew up in his face
he was on sean hannity's fox news
program last night
saying that what is to blame for the
power outages in texas
is the green new deal take a look
we just came off of a very difficult
week where the grid
failed four million texans and so we
need to have a serious examination
about why that was why the grid came
short
but one of the major elements of that is
actually the policy that schumer is
pushing for the whole country
which is the green new deal you look at
texas right now about 25 percent
of our electricity capacity is wind and
yet
in the middle of this storm that
capacity dropped
all the way down to two percent you want
to talk about reliability
the the reality was in the cold the wind
turbines froze
and and the power generation wasn't
there ted cruz manages to squeeze about
six lies into that short
40-second segment that i played for you
it's a great um
illustration of the problem we're
talking about so let's talk through it
first of all what texas did over the
last
10 15 years with their power grid it's
nothing like what the green new deal
would do
ted cruz wants you to believe that texas
went all
in on green energy and now has power
failures
and it's a preview of what happens to
the whole country
if the whole country goes in the
direction of green energy
texas did something that's the opposite
of the green new deal
texas isolated their power grid from the
rest of the country
to avoid so-called federal government
meddling and interference in their
energy market
former governor rick perry talked about
it last week we've heard from a number
of different people
bragging about we are an independent
grid
the green new deal doesn't call for that
and so what happened was that when the
grid was
stressed and we'll talk about why it was
stressed they couldn't get power from
anywhere else
has nothing to do with what is in the
green new deal and of course the green
new deal hasn't passed
second ted says wind energy is 25
of power generation capacity in texas
this is in theory accurate
texas can in theory get up to 24.8
percent of power from wind but that's
seasonal in the winter it's only a
fraction of that
last week when the power outages
happened 25 percent of
actual electricity was not coming from
wind power but
more importantly third when ted says
that energy generation capacity from
wind plummeted during the storm
that's true but it also plummeted even
more
for natural gas coal and nuclear on
which texas is significantly more
reliant
and the reason is not because of wind
power versus nuclear versus coal or gas
it's because texas chose not to
winterize
any of their power generation so they've
got an isolated grid
that can't up pull from any other part
of the country
and they opt not to winterize as i've
said a dozen times in the last week
back in 2011 texas had similar outages a
report was compiled explaining
how you prevent this in the future and
they just didn't do it and yes
some wind farms froze because they
weren't winterized
but the bigger problem was frozen
instruments at
coal natural gas and nuclear power
plants
which are not winterized everything ted
cruz is saying is a lie
now you might see this and write it off
and say
david how can the green new deal be to
blame for anything
it hasn't been passed it hasn't been
made law no one would fall for this
and yet they do just look at twitter
look at reddit look at the quote debates
happening on cable news right now this
stuff works
on lots of republicans when obamacare
was being debated
before it passed there were republicans
blaming obamacare for not being able to
get medical procedures wasn't the law
yet
protesters doing things last summer
were being blamed on this is biden's
america trump was president
millions of them fell for it and this is
sort of part of how
they blamed antifa for the january sixth
insurrection
incited by trump carried out by
trumpists
antifa had nothing to do with it so
unless
time travel is a factor that i somehow
don't understand
and that we've not yet been able to
explain and what we're talking about is
time moves in a different way than we
conceive of it there is no possible way
that the green new deal is responsible
but it doesn't matter to them
they are either falling for it or
knowingly accepting something that's
untrue
in order to try to point fingers
elsewhere uh it's disgusting
but it represents a barrier
in actually getting things done properly
winterizing
these electrical grids and continuing to
move to green energy which in many ways
is actually more robust in its ability
to resist changes in climate and weather
i don't know what the future is of this
talking point but my instinct is that
it's going to be around for a while
and if and when joe biden actually gets
around to moving forward on his green
new deal infrastructure green
infrastructure plan rather
which takes elements from the green new
deal i would assume
that many of these republicans are going
to fight it by saying
green new deal type stuff is responsible
for what happened in texas in 2021 it'll
be untrue of course
but it's clearly a talking point they're
going to repeat and repeat and repeat
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
keep grabbing those memberships at
joinpakman.com our number one
funding source at the show whether you
listen to the podcast or watch the
youtube channel however you consume the
content tick-tock even can you imagine
uh we are mostly supported by your
memberships
you can sign up right now at
joinpacman.com
after quite literally years of pushing
for this
the issue of donald trump's taxes has
made it to the supreme court
and the supreme court yesterday has
cleared the way
for donald trump's taxes to be released
very important detail
to be released to new york
prosecutors not to the public
or to the house of representatives you
might remember that donald trump said
during the 2016 campaign
that he would release his taxes as soon
as all of his audits were over
now in fact it's been 2 200 days
almost since donald trump said he'd
release his tax returns
he first said it in february of 2015. he
is not under
if it's even true that he's under audit
still it wouldn't be
for all of his years of taxes even if
you believe
that he shouldn't release his tax
returns while they are being audited
which is a question
he could release the ones that are not
being audited we
uh don't know if there were any audits
but it was all a lie
in the sense that donald trump never had
any intention
of releasing his tax returns because he
clearly calculated
he made the decision that whatever
damage would be done
by not releasing them would be vastly
outweighed by the damage if he did
release them well now after numerous
appeals
and legal arguments the supreme court
says
that indeed the records might be
shielded from public disclosure but it
is time for manhattan district attorney
cyrus vance to get those trump
tax returns for the purposes of his
investigations
into hush money payments made by donald
trump
and other possible financial fraud so
this
finally is a step closer to prosecutors
getting the documents
it may or may not be a step closer to
these documents being made public now
we all know anytime documents change
hands the possibility of a leak
becomes a reality how likely these would
be to leak from the manhattan d.a
when it would be known that that's who
had them
that remains to be seen but it's
happening there are no more appeals to
make
as was reported by nbc's pete williams
on msnbc yesterday quote
the new york grand jury will see trump's
tax returns almost immediately
this is the end of the road for the
president so a few different things
here it's absurd that it even
took this long and trump kept appealing
on different grounds and when a court
would decide against him he would
immediately appeal again
it's gotten to the supreme court it took
a long time trump's not even in
uh he's been talking about releasing his
tax returns since before being in office
he's now gone and this is only finally
moving forward now whether we ever see
the taxes at this point
i don't know and it's less relevant it's
more about
whether donald trump can actually get
away with hiding
his taxes forever and fro from everyone
and it seems that at least the from
everyone is becoming a hard no
as prosecutors are going to get them and
the grand jury is going to look at them
now
as i've said before donald trump's legal
expenses
for the foreseeable future are going to
be formidable if he pays his lawyers
which is always a caveat with donald
trump and meanwhile
just as a reminder there are still
conspiracy theorists mostly of the q
anon persuasion
who believe that we are just days from
donald trump getting back in office
march
4th is the new date that many of them
have set
they believe as we've talked about a
week or two ago
that due to a technicality relating to
the fact that inauguration
used to be on march 4th before being
moved to january 20th
that somehow donald trump is going to go
back to power and back to being
president on march 4th
this decision by the supreme court for
the very conspiratorial types
is an attempt at interfering with trump
getting back in power on march 4th
how it has anything to do with it i
don't know obviously
trump was never going to get back in
power on march 4th but
when it doesn't happen on march 4th many
of these q anon types will say
that it was because of this supreme
court decision
meant to i don't even know but
it's apparently a big factor in what's
going on so
we'll wait and see on all of this stuff
including
if and when the tax returns ever become
public the decision
did cause donald trump to explode and
that's what i want to talk about next
we have gone over the decision from the
supreme court
from yesterday which said you can't
shield your tax returns from manhattan
prosecutors anymore
donald trump that's the decision made by
the supreme court the documents
with reportedly almost no delay will be
turned over to manhattan district
attorney cyrus vance
and will be made part of the grand jury
that cyrus vance is running okay
donald trump exploded
at news of this putting out a statement
on the quote continuing political pro
persecution
of president donald trump this is a very
funny letter
in which donald trump alternates between
referring to himself in the first person
and the third person
it's riddled with lots of other wacky
things and
i want to go through it with you because
it is actually incredible
that this is a letter from a former
president of the united states
it's almost like a third grader wrote a
joke letter
let's get right into it quote this
investigation is a continuation of the
greatest political witch hunt
which hunt capitalized we'd never know
why in the history of our
country whether it was the never-ending
32 million dollar
molar hoax which remember recovered far
more than the 32 million that it cost
trump goes on to say which already
investigated everything that could
possibly be investigated russia russia
russia
where there was a finding of no
collusion that's
of course untrue or two ridiculous
crazy nancy inspired impeachment
attempts
where i was found not guilty it never
ends
so now for more than two years new york
city has been looking at almost every
transaction i've ever done
including seeking tax returns which were
done by among the biggest and most
prestigious law and accounting firms in
the united states
now remember when you have someone do
your taxes
you are always signing off and saying
you
are warranting that the information you
give to them is true
they are merely completing the taxes
based on what you tell them
so the idea that the prestige of the
accounting firm
when i go and i tell our accountant uh
here's how much we made
here's how much we spent the accountant
has me sign something where i where i am
saying
it is my responsibility if this
information is untrue if i'm
lying about the value of a building or
whatever that's on me that's not on the
account
the prestige of the accounting firm
seems irrelevant okay continuing
uh the tea party was treated far better
by the irs than donald trump
the supreme court never should have let
this fishing expedition happen but they
did
now what's funny is trump puts fishing
expedition in quotes
that suggests it's trump who's skeptical
that it was actually
a fishing expedition trump doesn't seem
to understand
what quotes mean going on to say this is
something which has never happened to a
president before
it is all democrat inspired in a totally
democrat location new york city and
state
completely controlled and dominated by a
heavily reported enemy of mine governor
andrew cuomo now if trump has any
evidence that cuomo
is involved in any of this he should
release it there is no evidence i've
seen so far
trump continues these are attacks by
democrats willing to do anything to stop
the almost 75 million people the most
votes by far ever gotten by a sitting
president
who voted for me in the election an
election which many people and experts
feel that i won
i agree so trump still can't get away
from the it was stolen
stuff that incited the riot in the first
place
the new phenomenon of head hunting
prosecutors and ag's who try to take
down
their political opponents using the law
as a weapon
is a threat to the very foundation of
our liberty that's what is done in third
world countries
even worse for those who run for
prosecutorial or attorney general
offices in far-left states and
jurisdictions
pledging to take out a political
opponent that's fascism not justice
funny that trump talks about third world
countries and fascism
trump's presidency and his
authoritarianism was more reminiscent of
that
than anything we're seeing right now
trump goes on to say and that is exactly
what they are trying to do with respect
to me
except that the people of our country
won't stand for it in the meantime
murders and violent crime are up in new
york city by record numbers
and nothing is done about it yeah mostly
under trump's presidency
our elected officials don't care all
they focus on is the persecution
of president donald j trump i will fight
on just as i have for the last five
years even before i was successfully
elected
despite all of the election crimes that
were committed against me
we will win and it's unclear what
exactly
trump believes he is going to win to me
this is the rantings of a highly
triggered but in particular very scared
individual remember there are political
consequences
to some degree of a presidential
candidate not releasing their tax
returns trump knew that
and he still decided releasing them
is worse for me than keeping them
private
keeping them secret and being criticized
for it
that means trump knows the content of
the tax returns is not good for him and
that's why he's acting in this way
uh what do you think is in the tax
returns
i've explained my thoughts many times
before uh
and at this point do you think it even
matters we'll have more coverage of this
on our instagram page david pakman show
and if you want to see the level of
anti-vaxx
emails that we are now getting check my
personal instagram
david.pakman where i posted a really
extreme
anti-vaxx email that i received this
morning quick break
much more coming up the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking with
chris
smalls who is a former amazon employee
who has become
a leader of the e-commerce and labor
rights
movement chris is going to tell us about
his work for and his subsequent
firing from amazon now of course
we haven't been able to independently
confirm
uh chris's story but it is a compelling
one
and i am more than open to having
someone from amazon on to talk to us
about the things that chris is going to
tell us uh
chris you have a background that started
similar to mine which is your background
is in retail i worked at the
now defunct circuit city when i
was much younger you worked at walmart
and target
uh but let's talk a little bit about
your work for uh for amazon how did you
come to work
at amazon i started working on amazon
back in 2015.
i came in entry level i came from
before amazon i was working at a grocery
distribution warehouse
overnight graveyard shift it was
unionized but uh
the union contract just wasn't what i
expected it to be
so i thought that i have a better
opportunity at amazon
i opened up the first building in
carteret new jersey ewr9
uh stayed there for about two years and
then i transferred to bdl2 connecticut
and then my last facility was jfka
staten island so i've been with the
company for almost four and a half years
and what was your day-to-day like what
kind of roles were you in
so when i became when i first got hired
i was entry level i was a
uh what they call a picker uh i
my job was to pick customer items in a
timely manner within the hour
uh hourly rate of about uh back then it
was about 250 items an hour
now it's a lot more it's about 400 now
but i did that for about
six to seven months and then i was
promoted up to a process assistant
better known as an assistant manager and
i was in that position for the last four
years
now as an assistant manager were you
supervising pickers
yes i actually uh supervising pickers
uh and then it expanded to a different
operation
which now i was uh in control of three
different departments
so picking uh counting and also uh
um floor health so floor health was also
a part of the department as well
okay so many people in my audience have
probably seen
the articles that talk about the
conditions for the pickers and they
include things like
um you're not allowed to go to the
bathroom and there's this constant
pressure to pick more and more and more
and the conditions are bad
and your breaks are monitored down to
the minute talk a little bit about what
what if that was true
when you were there is any of it not
true
no it's 100 true amazon is ran
completely off of metrics and numbers
uh they calculate everything it is
actually calculated down to the second
you know the second you stop scanning
the item uh
your time accu accumulates uh of time
off task
so um i was a part of that machine i
very much had to monitor
my associates in my department but um
like i said i was just a supervisor that
um related to them so uh they respected
the fact that i wasn't that type of
supervisor that would be hard on them
if they came back late from break or
whatever the case may be because i know
uh how massive these buildings are and
how the working conditions can take a
toll on your body
now were you pressured even though you
weren't
pressuring the pickers maybe the way
that you would be expected to did that
cause a problem for you
absolutely i mean um for the most part
it caused a problem with my own personal
career growth
because obviously management um knew
that i would never side with them when
it came to certain things like that
um you know i was kind of like the black
sheep of the
supervisors everybody knew that i had a
backbone
and i always spoke up for what was right
and i always sided with the employees at
entry level because that's where i
started from i never forgot where i came
from
and it didn't bother me but it
definitely hindered my career there
you know i applied for a salary manager
position there 49 times and i i was
denied every last one of them
and it's probably because the fact that
they knew that i would never be
fully uh pro amazon were you what reason
were you given the 49 times
why you weren't going to be given the
salaried manager
well from my own personal experiences it
was
it was basically bogus um a lot of the
interviews were
set up for me to fail from the beginning
a lot of them the interviews they
already knew who they wanted
in those positions before i even applied
so it was a combination of a lot of
different things
also there was uh you know letters and
and management
above me that didn't like me as a person
you know whatever the case may be
so it was a lot of different things of
why um i didn't get those positions
and i believe it's systemic you know
systemic racism that exists inside
amazon as well
over a million and a half employees
worldwide and only
and then 26 years of existence only
eight percent of the management is black
or brown
so that just tells you right there the
higher up the food chain the less likely
you know you are to be colored so um
i even believe this for the first time
this past year they have
one black woman that's on the senior
team you know so that just tells you
right there
the chances of me getting promoted up
the ladder was slim
and chris i'm not i'm not familiar with
the numbers you're citing so i'm curious
when you say eight percent
is that globally or in the united states
that's globally
that's globally okay do you know what it
is in the united states
i would guess it would be a lot less
than that you know i'm pretty sure
um it's not too many of us up at the top
you know once again
in this this company's 26 or 27 years of
existence
for the first time ever they put one
black woman on that the senior team
uh the s team they call it so that just
tells you right there they're way behind
eight ball when it comes to diversity
when it comes to management were there
ways in which uh
working at amazon was better than when
you did
actual customer facing retail like
walmart and target
of course you know um i worked at
competitors and i worked
during the holiday season um and you
know
nothing's worse than working black
friday right at the time
you got customers trying to get their
items and and
the lines are backed up and everything's
chaos
chaos so uh working in the warehouse um
you have to deal with customers
it's a benefit but um once again it's
also calisthenics you know so i used to
tell
my my employees new hires if you have a
gym membership you might want to cancel
it
now um ultimately you you were fired by
amazon can you talk about why
yeah absolutely you know last year uh
the beginning of the pandemic
late february early march when this
virus
came into the country in seattle killing
the senior citizens over there i
i was afraid over here on the east coast
and i tried to raise health and safety
concerns going through the proper
channels
um and after doing that for a few weeks
i
i tried organizing workers inside the
the warehouse sitting in the cafeteria
10 hours a day off the clock
i'm telling many as many workers as i
can after i learned in the meeting
with my bosses that uh we had cases in
the facility and they didn't want me to
tell
anybody not to cause a panic or disrupt
business
um so i felt that i had to take further
action and after a whole week of
advocating
i'm pleading going back and forth with
the general manager of the building
um they decide to quarantine just me
other than everybody else and that
didn't make sense to me
not even the person i ride to work with
none of the people in my department that
was around the person who was infected
um it was just me so i do they were
using me as a target
and um as a result i held a protest on
march 30th
outside of my facility and then two
hours later i was terminated over the
phone
a week after that uh jeff bezos and his
top general counsel
david sapolsky uh they tried to run a
smear campaign on me calling me not
smart or articulate
and make me the whole face of the whole
unionizing efforts
so there's a couple different things
here right i mean the one is
that the part about infections at the
facility
and the other is trying to organize uh
the the uh the workers so let's talk
about the first one first
so you were told by by managers
not to talk about the fact that there
were infected employees
absolutely yes on march 24th we had an
uh our daily sync meeting which we have
every single day
and that's pretty much giving us the
rundown for the rest of the day
and how it's supposed to go but on that
day it was different uh that day they
told us we had a case
that was actually two weeks prior
for the first time and they pretty much
told
the supervisors not to say anything and
i just felt that was
uh wrong i felt like i had to say
something that took my stance there that
was the last day i worked for amazon
so that was a supervisor's meeting and
you guys were told not to mention the
case to the employees you supervise
absolutely okay and then separately
but around the same time you were
working to organize the workers there
and what was the point of the
organization to approach management
about
virus-related matters or to collectively
bargain on salary and benefits
well actually that was the first time i
learned about it
i haven't even started organizing yet
that was march 24th
what i was doing was behind the scenes i
was sending out emails to the governor
to governor cuomo's office to the cdc
department
of manhattan now media i was trying to
fight behind the scenes uh it wasn't
until after that meeting the next day
when i came back to the facility
um i told my supervisor i won't be
working for the remain of the week
and that's when i started to go in the
cafeteria and tell all the workers that
i
came in contact with the truth that you
possibly been
working around somebody who tested
positive um from that point forward
what we did every morning uh a small
group of us
marched into the general manager's
office and voiced our concerns
yeah uh has this thing called uh voice
of associates
where associates are allowed to write on
the board uh their complaints
so i said you know what here is your
your voiceover
associates board uh right here in person
uh here's our complaints we wanted the
building to just be simply closed down
and sanitized we would have came back to
work no problem and that's all we wanted
in the beginning but obviously
a lot more now what was officially given
to you as the reason why you were being
let go
oh they claimed that i violated socially
this is policies that
none of us ever read are ever you know
implemented you know
as a supervisor i'm supposed to receive
the policies and relay
that information that i never did so
they didn't exist because
they didn't know what we were dealing
with you know and that's all
um it was okay to understand that they
didn't know what they were dealing with
how to
handle it but uh to ignore the fact that
workers
with underlying health conditions you
know mothers that were pregnant
uh parents that have children at home
including myself
were afraid to come to work and refuse
to listen to us that's a whole other
story
when it comes to what you're fighting
for now if i understand correctly
you're looking to organize a sort of a
non-union nationwide group of workers am
i right that you're going the non-union
approach and what made you decide to go
about it that way
um yeah you know i i feel like with
amazon there's such a large entity in uh
a large business that uh you know it
actually would be kind of difficult for
one
union to try to unionize the entire
nation
uh we're talking 800 000 workers so i
felt like an organization
that has a worker driven committee
would be more beneficial for amazon
workers uh something that's working
employee
controlled uh but union-like structure
you know i feel like that's the best way
possible it's sort of like cutting out
the middleman
uh no you know no union duels or
whatever the case may be
but workers are allowed to sit in on
negotiation negotiate their own
contracts
and then now we all we also have enough
power
um workers power that if congress said
you know you're an essential worker
and you have to go to work in the middle
of a pandemic right we're going to say
no we're not going to work until we have
you know a ppe provided by the company
hazard pay
medical leave all these things that
we're demanding
uh before we consider ourselves
essential workers
so that's interesting so absent the act
the
the actual union with the dues sort of
like at what level would you see this
working would it be at the individual
facility level would be at a regional
level or how do you how would you
structure that
yeah you know i thought about it and i
think uh regional would be better
um if you had just one uh you know you
break down the country into regions
uh you have a committee a workplace
committee um
that represents that region because we
know the cost of living
in different parts of the country is
different
these committees negotiate the contract
and there you go
that be able to you know take care of
the mass of the employees that work for
amazon
with unionizing you have to do a
facility by facility
and that's going to be a longer process
as you can see what they're doing in
alabama
they're prolonging it the union busting
yeah um they're firing workers they're
hiring workers
they're doing all these things to
disrupt it but if you have a workplace
committee that's something that's built
internally uh it's gonna be hard to
uh bust that up did you ever see or
experience um or become aware of
sort of like not union busting but maybe
union prevention activity by amazon
absolutely as a supervisor you know i
watched uh
you know those training videos we had to
take tests assessment tests
they tried to mix in uh certain
questions that
uh obviously related to union busting
but um i never applied them you know
like i said i was
i'm always uh on the employee uh entry
level position
side so i never applied these things you
know obviously
there was management that though that
you know applied that
and they still do um but you know you
just have to understand what you're
dealing with you're dealing with a
company that does
that's anti-union from the beginning
and now we see that it's very much
necessary that they
are unionized yeah i remember in my
early days at circuit city they sat me
down and mixed in with training videos
about like how to use the sales systems
and what the process is for requesting
time off
they throw in videos about you know we
want to maintain a direct relationship
with employees
we don't want any intermediaries or
middlemen and it was very
it was very sophisticated in fact the
way that it was done
oh yeah yeah the same thing you know uh
they mixing
the questions with like safety and
hazmat and all this training and i'm
like well
you know you read between the lines yeah
uh we've been speaking with chris smalls
former amazon employee
now a leader of the e-commerce labor
rights movement chris i really
appreciate your time and we're going to
continue following your great work
absolutely i appreciate you guys for
giving me a chance to tell my story
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so we expected it to happen and it
finally is my pillow ceo mike lindell
who i refer to as mike pillow has been
sued
by dominion voting systems because of
his continued and persistent
bogus weaponized election fraud claims
mike lindell
is a right-wing pillow manufacturer
based in minnesota he mostly advertises
on right-wing media like fox news and
newsmax and oan
or some combination of those he became
close to the president
when he showed up at the white house
relatively early in the coronavirus
pandemic
and was part of a sort of promotional
tour in which
donald trump announced that uh these
various companies that love
trump will be retooling their factories
to make n95 masks we don't really know
if
or when that actually happened but in
any case at his speech
thanking donald trump for his
involvement in making ppe
mike lindell said that he believes
donald trump is
a gift from god and it only went
downhill
from there in the post-election period
mike lindell became sort of a fixture on
right-wing media and various wacky kooky
podcasts saying
he has all the proof it was stolen by
joe biden and dominion voting systems
was a big part of it
he will now have to mount a legal
defense and if he really does have the
proof
that dominion did whatever it is he
thinks they did in the 2020 election
he's going to get the chance to prove it
because that's what you get to do in
defamation
cases dominion is seeking more than 1.3
billion dollars in damages
the lawsuit says that mike lindell quote
exploited
false claims about election fraud to
support
his company's sales and mike lindell has
responded by saying quote
i'm very happy that they've done this
i'm ready to go to court
i have all the evidence that anyone
would ever
want to see now you might remember that
in an interview with the new york times
uh last month early february i believe
it was in january
lindell said he welcomes a lawsuit from
dominion they had sent him a sort of
legal letter
warning him if you don't stop we will
sue and we might sue anyway
and they have sued and i guess we'll see
how it all works out
for mike pillow now this is going to be
a mic pillow
this is going to be fascinating because
as has been the issue with defamation
lawsuits for a long time
defamation statutes have been a thing
for a while
uh proving that what you said is true is
a valid defense to defamation
if mike pillow's allegations are true
it is by definition not defamation
defamation can take
two forms slander or libel slander is
a spoken defamation libel is written
defamation if mike pillow can prove
that dominion voting systems and again
it's hard to understand what he even
claims but
if mike pillow can prove that they did
whatever he claims that they did
he would be off scot-free and wouldn't
be liable
for anything now i love the idea
of mike having to go to court with his
so-called evidence but
my guess is if i had to bet on it
that whatever lawyers mike lindell
actually hires are going to tell him
mike the way to fight this is not to go
to court and try to prove
voter fraud i can't imagine any serious
lawyer
would even take this case if the
strategy is going to be we're going to
go in there and prove
that dominion did whatever it is mike
lindell claims that they did it will
either be pled out or settled
mike lindell might end up apologizing
like alex jones has about i think it was
chobani yogurt or something like that
and it actually reminds me of if you
think back to
not that long ago trump's second
impeachment his first
uh cadre of lawyers quit
and one of the bits of of
news that we got around that was that
trump wanted that first
slate of attorneys to defend trump
by proving the election was stolen
therefore
legitimizing or legitimating yes that's
a word
legitimizing the um
inciting of the riot and reportedly
trump's first slate of lawyers said
that's a crazy idea
uh word that doesn't make sense they
ended up parting ways
but ultimately trump's legal team did
not defend him by saying
the election was stolen they defended
him by saying he didn't actually incite
the riot
so um we will follow this remember that
rudy giuliani has also been sued by
dominion voting systems
and uh we're going to follow it and see
where this ultimately ends up
cpac the conservative political action
conference
is this weekend it is going to be a
an amalgam of a disgusting cast of
characters
culminating on sunday with a speech yes
from former president donald trump his
first
on-camera speech since leaving the white
house
more than a month ago and we are going
to be covering that live on sunday
but cpac is running into a little bit of
a problem
cpac uh it turns out invited a speaker
who goes by the name young pharaoh
and unfortunately young pharaoh has said
horribly anti-semitic things including
completely hare-brained wacky cuckoo for
cocoa puffs
conspiracy theories and pharaoh young
pharaoh
has now been pulled as a speaker the
daily beast reports
that young pharaoh once tweeted out
there is no historical
or scientific evidence proving the
existence of
jews or judaism it's all a complete lie
made up for political gain he also
attacked fellow right-wing
commentator ben shapiro for his judaism
according to media matters he also has
conspiracies
about uh pizzagate the coronavirus
vaccine
and a whole bunch of other things as
reported
by eric hananoki he
a young pharaoh in the past year claimed
that
judaism in itself is a quote complete
lie
that the jewish people are thieving
and that all of the censorship and
pedophilia
mind you on social media is being done
by
israeli jews specifically
um he has now been pulled now one of the
funniest aspects of this and it's funny
in a way that's tragic
is that cpac put out a statement
saying quote we have just learned that
someone we invited to cpac has expressed
reprehensible views that have no
home with our conference or our
organization
the individual will not be participating
in our conference the funny thing about
that is
it essentially applies to everybody that
is speaking at cpac
up to and including donald trump i mean
look at look at the wording
someone we invited expressed
reprehensible views
that trump is at the absolute top of
that list
so if they were going to go by that
standard
um cpac would have to be canceled what
cpac actually means
is someone's reprehensible views went
beyond being considered reprehensible
only by the left and even some people on
the right consider these views
reprehensible
so at this point we really have no
choice uh but to cancel
the speaking engagement of young pharaoh
now speaking of cancellation
one of the new prominent memes
on the right around free speech and
suppression of speech is so-called
left-wing cancel culture
which includes of course at the micro
level and i'm doing my best to represent
the the hypothesis uh left-wing
individuals
employers and organizations quote
canceling people
when they have the quote wrong opinion
about things and it goes up to and is
inclusive of
twitter at large including its terms of
service
big picture youtube facebook basically
anyone who has ever
limited the ability of right wingers to
continue publishing
weaponized speech uh including that
which targets
all sorts of different individuals based
on membership in different protected
classes
that's cancel culture according to the
right but what's very funny
or maybe it's not funny maybe it's just
sad and ironic is that
uh when uh fox news canceled
lou dobbs because lou dobbs was giving a
ridiculously uh um uh not based in fact
opinion
about the election of uh joe biden in
november
fox news said he's got to go and they
canceled lou dobbs
and yet in the days following in all of
the segments about cancel culture on fox
news and newsmax and oan
they didn't mention lou dobbs being
cancelled now
the right-wing conservative political
action conference
has cancelled a right-wing commentator
for his opinions that's not part of the
cancel culture
even though they won't stop talking
about bill de blasio this
and twitter that and susan wojcicki
wizki
that other thing based on what youtube
twitter or others are doing so
even the idea that they care about
cancel culture
is laughably untrue they care only about
instances of repercussions to speech
that are politically advantageous for
them that's all it is
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
we talked earlier in the show about
vaccine alarmism which is different than
anti-vax anti-vax is also a big problem
from the standpoint of the coronavirus
vaccine
here is a caller who sounds like he's in
a really tough
situation with his parents at home take
a listen to this
hi david this is christian from uh baton
rouge louisiana
i was just wondering if you could speak
on
the safety of the vaccine because
my parent who's a clinical physician
has pretty much told me
that if i take the vaccine that they
won't talk to me
wow because they're so scared of it and
i mean practically everyone i know
is not taking the vaccine out of fear
that
it's rushed or that it's gonna hurt them
i just i don't see how doctors can think
this
and it not be true it is very
scary that many health care workers
including doctors and nurses
are uncritically repeating some of the
same
debunked derogatory talking points about
the vaccine
that people who you know do research by
looking at the articles shared by their
crazy cousin on facebook
every single one of these claims has
been debunked the vaccine wasn't
rushed the mrna-based platform for
making vaccines
has been in play for more than a decade
at this point and
part of it is that once you have the
platform in place
the individual vaccine takes far less
time to develop so that's
one piece that's been answered the
question about
vaccine safety there uh i actually i
have an exchange with an anti-vaxxer
that i might publish soon via via email
but one of the talking points that they
talk about is
someone died during vaccine testing and
what they are referring to is an
individual
in brazil who died of covet
complications while
part of the vaccine trial it was later
determined that they were in the placebo
group
that individual did not even receive
the vaccine very important to understand
and then in terms of long-term effects i
mean listen we've talked about this
before
you can always say there might be some
effect
over a time period that is longer than
the time period the vaccine has been out
if a vaccine has been out for 20 years
you could always say we don't know if
the vaccine
doesn't have negative long-term effects
that you only learn about after 21 years
if a vaccine's been out 50 years you can
say what if the negative effects start
after
51 years what we do know uh
is that the negative effects
that are known about vaccines tend to
happen
uh within the first couple of weeks and
that is it
and that historically there was a
vaccine
a long time ago that over the long term
incr increased your
risk of being diagnosed with
guillain-barre syndrome and i believe it
changed it from
a one in two million to one in one
million
that is an old vaccine i'm going from
memory i believe it was an
early polio vaccine although i may be
wrong about that please don't hold me to
it
and we know a lot about these things so
it's scary that a doctor is telling
their kid
if you get vaccinated i won't talk to
you unfortunately
the virus of antivax has infected
many areas of american society and
that's a very very scary thing
but hopefully anti-vac sentiment will
decline
it has been declining at one point in
may of 2020
60 of the country said they weren't
interested in the covid vaccine
that dropped to 50 40 30. latest numbers
i saw are that about a quarter
of the country doesn't want the vaccine
and the number keeps declining with time
that's good and hopefully as vaccine
supply becomes available
vaccine interest will also increase
we've got a great bonus show for you
today california
is going with their own coveted relief
package very interesting we will discuss
it
we also have new obstacles to the
confirmation of joe biden's nominee nira
tandon this is a nominee i opposed from
day one
and now it is actually looking like more
and more of an uphill battle for near
attendant thanks to a couple of
republicans that's a good thing
i'll tell you why and lastly treasury
secretary janet yellen
has sounded a warning about bitcoin
we will talk about that and much more on
today's bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code
pacman